to another Android office hours from the
Sun wats snowy London my name is Matt
gone i'm joined with chris bones yep and
we're going to be discussing all things
android usual disclaimer we don't talk
about future releases or future
announcements or anything we might be
doing we're literally here to talk about
the api's got and try and help you guys
out so yeah sorry a bit later died
rabuck gotta definitely technical
difficulties one after the other yeah
but way we're here it's all good and
we've got rich and giuseppe as well in
the hang up hey does fe how you doing
and people ello mate thank you guys hey
hey i just joined in case i could help
with the technical difficulties but i'm
actually in a mountain view at the
moment so it's kind of six o'clock in
the morning so i'm gonna drop out and
leave these guys to it I was useless
anyway I'll catch you guys later Cheers
a room yeah we wore our jet lag how
things are you better be happy but oh
great a little bit tired but it's the
flu season so everybody's a little bit
sick yeah how good yeah I just about
managed to stay away from that from CES
um right interesting to see yes n when
you wait yes lots of new Google TV
devices sure people was keen to see so
yeah we announced partnerships of the
asus netgear TCL LG announced a new set
of tvs as the Hisense so yeah it was
amazing yep johanna involved i sent her
massive billboards and his snap films up
everywhere but ya know it's really
really good event really fun laser stuff
lots of miracast devices as well would
work so yeah that's good
cool so any questions in the room so
Georgia your bio Lumia oh yeah and
everything down yeah so that Ganges at
be excused himself everyone's have you
technically shows up well leave I know
you have a question because it is in the
moderate I said you want to ask it live
there yeah um now what we see we see
more televisions we should she and watch
smart watches we see google glasses so i
was wondering if there's a good
technique to do better pair with
different devices and I mean the Wi-Fi
direct is the way you would like this
sort of prescribed by doing it for now
on really and so network discovery but
the acronym is in yes and yes and so
that's sort of there's a big train
sample on developer android com which is
actually really good so yeah I mean that
as though I also appoint you to men
because it's gonna be bundled through
Android from now on and it's you have
quicker sort of p2p access things I've
Latif and so that's the odds say and see
ya yeah I think for me it I don't think
we've got to this point where we've got
like a unified API one one size fits all
I think like obviously Google TV we have
any motor that's very much case a few
flings tough to the TV you can discover
it that you can't then start going
backwards then when you start took about
smartwatches obviously all of them are
using bluetooth is their way of
communication you don't have Wi-Fi so i
don't think there is just a one solution
fix all obviously if there's a surface
that you can use that does all this for
you then look into obviously you start
buying into something that if they
suddenly decide to stop supporting here
or they change it or something this new
device they don't want to support your
kind of tied into that point so yeah I
think the nds stuff is probably quite a
safe way to go um but yeah just try and
do whatever you think is best
fix it right the escalation don't just
try and bear in mind future down the
line that you may need to talk about no
I will follow the tutorial online them
yeah yeah it's a nice tutorial not
scoping that So Def your waffle cool
thank you cheers anyway just got more
guys Scott Yossi hi guys hey have fun I
have a little question yeah if I can ask
or is this under someone else on the
line and there is book guy friend and
ask a question okay I'm trying to see to
do some POC about video view and what
I'm trying to do is basically have a
full screen video view inside a view
pager and on the video L I want to show
some custom buttons but every time i'll
try try to to load the video to the
video view i get an error that the video
you cannot play the file even though
when commenting all the buttons or all
the draw balls on top of the video view
the file place correctly any known issue
about this or something like that that's
very weak you're definitely just using
plain old video view using muddy cheap
Larry no no no video view from the
Android one
cause an issue have you tried with the
buttons but not in a viewpager yeah also
the same result what doesn't know it
does it doesn't work where she'll video
shows coming from from the SD card i
have it on an SD card also tried to do
it on the raw data files and the
permissions is set correctly sorry
didn't hear you the permission is set
correctly the ice is of course I can if
I just do a simple view with the video
view on it and attach the media file and
I just click on it and in place
correctly and the only problem is when
I'm starting to add image buttons or any
other text views or overlays on it
inside the relative layout or linearly
whatever you want and the view doesn't
doesn't play the video and video view is
basically a glorified surface year with
lock integrated media player from
charity and surface he controls
differently to other views if sort of
punches rock for the window so android
doesn't sort of optimizations and stuff
to get equal to each other I'll have a
look at the surface you documentation
because I remember there being a flag on
there where you can sort of set
compatibility mode to make it sort of
draw things on top I karma roughed up my
head he's been a while since I've used
it and I have like a surface human that
that sort of that classy documentation
because I'm pretty sure the flag on them
ok I'll try to see it and another
question I didn't encountered it but we
have a view pager with the surface view
on it and basically when you do the
scrolling the scroll from side to side
you see a black surface the view doesn't
render from one view page switch to
another you know like on the camera and
when you switch from live video to the
gallery
see the galleries is sorry has a black
overlay recent parties because the wife
said he works in that he punches for all
the windows so imagine your surfaces
right at the back of your views and it's
all punches through so what you actually
seen is the very back window the black
that's what the black is and it's just
because the weight drawers is different
to offer views and there's no real way
around it unfortunately and other than
not using a service you obviously it
easily be going after yeah I didn't see
it until now we try to do something with
the camera preview and just do a
viewpager scrolling left to right and we
saw that the basically the view doesn't
completely renders because and the Nexus
galaxy nexus with the jellybean it works
flawlessly you don't see the black
rendering and on different devices like
on the samsung s2 or s3 you see the
black window stays until the full window
is been switched in it this is probably
fix in jellybean then but oh it's just
why such as he works from why not okay
thanks guys I'll try hi hey answer
question yeah go for it okay so I have
two questions please the first one is
how to change the stack overflow icon
programmatically like when switching
when I have that much about action power
flow switches programmatically any idea
you want to switch the icon daikon yeah
whatever scenario is that i have several
well i have a split action bar the
action bar and then the action mode as
well which is the contextual action bar
another term for it and i have two
different backgrounds from the
for the action bar for the extra mind
the split action bar but in there both
the contrast to one another so so the
overflow looks hidden in one on the dark
if it's a light and light and it looks
hidden on the in vice versa um that ISIL
it really is too young and not younger
group of a great implementation action
bar just shoes actually access without
we do it in your pocket that's not what
well you know I think access the source
of the drawable so you can change ok ok
thank you and my second question is I
try I want to play think Alice on door
hi hey can you please turn off the
microphone I thank you we have
background noises the microphone up the
earphones so I really just need
everything after work ok thanks so yeah
my second question regarding or HLS
mimetype i want to i understand that
Android as of three point Oh supports a
chill s playing and well it's kind of I
had problems with it but on for it they
got fixed but there isn't any mime type
there isn't any HS mime type that the
triggers the activity of of the player I
just I wrote again I gave the wrong line
type to like HLS just for a little tied
2-2 pop to the default a a glare
activity to pop up but what's the mime
type what was the form of my type the
default player supports virtualize
school I think
hls you that you want to package it
offers proof and before I think and then
there is something in that file which
will then yeah so that's what i did i
ran i gave the MP MP floral i'm tired
and trans but there there there may be
players that spoil them mp4 but not at
you less so it'll be the android
platform that will be supporting head to
less i mean the way you'd want to do it
if you want you to ensure the players
that thinspo hls one getting way done
when using that file then you'd want to
be basically i'm going to show more but
sorry didn't get it android version code
if you only wanted to play the heytell
extreme on Android and above so how do i
run only the activity of I I need to run
specifically they build up layers of
activity right the admin i invoke intent
to run the activity i'm not using it the
player as part of of the app yeah so
what you want to do is invoke the
activity you want to invoke that
activity depending on which version of
android you're running is that right but
for a chalice yeah but for example
samsung is perhaps samsung implement
their own
to me DN it's a different package name
or something believe what you want to be
doing so because the action underscore
view style in technical okay thanks it's
an mp4 file piece about the weather
awesome patient is capable of playing or
advocating chance to basically really
missing those okay so let's look at the
but there's the delay here sorry i I'm
listening so the only person i was gonna
say is essential versions of android
your intellectual incorrectly you're
basically just want to make sure that we
launched our intent on those versions of
android and above okay but the problem
is that if i run the intent with multi
with MP MP with mp4 mime type what will
happen is that players that support
template for will catch this but the i
saw some place that support mpeg-4 but
do not support HLS which is kind of a
wrapper around and before that's right
but or MP but they still don't support
it could you post in the chat like which
device is you're referring to and maybe
we can have a little thick round it's
more like what players are supported
because if the person support if users
is installed two players that support
mpeg-4 but from that from the play store
it installed two players that support
mpeg-4 but not HLS they won't play my my
video i guess it depends cuz if i'm
using a player which is implementing
their own media codecs and their own
encoding decoding and then i'm going to
be relying on the Android system so
which point yeah it's I guess the
difficult way would be trying to get
across to a user I mean the obvious
choice is to since you know you're going
to be able to run it on certain derisive
Android run it in a video of you and
then that way
how to get control of it there's the
media control is enough to do any
controls or happening fast forward
rewinding etc so it should be relatively
trivial just to add in your own video of
you which might be a good way just to
get around this yes so how do I skip
around implementing all the the
controllers they netted a fast forward a
this this seek to bar and stuff again so
when you create a video you can just
also set a media controller and then
providing you set that media controller
which again is just a class that it's
just handed to you feel just the video
gear for you ok ok ok so um can we can
request to add them the HLS mime type in
future releases that goes on too much
larger issue of the way HLS kind of
handles itself so it's not necessarily
my type I think that would be more to do
with a standard issue of an Android just
sitting there saying because i use it
for android only i think it would need
to be a slightly bigger discussion so
look yeah I don't think that's something
we couldn't necessarily do because like
I say I think it's one of those things
that Apple's obviously ok the standard
made it so that mp4 is the way of
dealing with it that's kind of standard
yeah maybe you'll change ok so it's kind
of more of them of the just activity of
the media player just the activity then
they sense that the activity of the
media players can handle that's it right
yeah exactly ok ok ok thanks Rosa yes
anyone else have a question and I am
right yeah shows on door thank you so
the as you get up to and after that
music with that relies on my IQs eight
API okay
and i choose a random song selected by
genre and then i play in the user must
again said the name and the artistic but
I provide a registration for this to
have the rankings and so on but do I
have to provide a privacy policy inside
the after on or on the wood'll a store
where they appropriate section so I
think the Play Store changed its
regulations regarding the privacy policy
is it you have to have one now or you
either have to have one or you're
explicitly say you're not going to
provide one ok my recommendation would
be definitely to have one on the Play
Store and then if you've got a
convenient place where you can have it
in the oven it makes sense if you have
any out like in terms of you've got a
settings page you can just put at the
end of their we've got a nice easy way
of keeping the two in sync I tried to go
with that I don't see any reason if
you've already gone to the time to
prepare it and you've got a spot where
it could literally out without being in
the way then I'd say just include it but
I don't think it's required ok but if
not the legal problem if I can put it in
their butt inside yeah it's not a legal
problem in terms of astex more of a
legal problem I guess between you and
the user I can't really consider that
much but i guess not illegal no it's
because i don't know if i'm afraid the
privacy policy because the user to me is
data ok and so I I not protect this data
and I have to say okay these data are
story the protected ok and you're right
I would always bond all the prophecy
paula smith yeah just in case your app
isn't isn't distributed with Play Store
so if it goes into am Stan app store or
any other sort of distribution channel
and they don't allow you to show a
privacy policy it's always going to be
with your arm so it's a fail-safe so
honored what I would always do it if you
made the if you've done that makes of
took the time to create one
shove me in your assets hold and then
crying a webview it's not much work okay
thank you okay I guess it kind of leads
onto a slightly wider picture of you
round then it kind of if usually goes to
the time to actually hum that out then
it probably means a slightly concerned
about your app and it's probably a good
way of just kind of putting on my knees
yeah and were looking at is on okay
thank you save any more questions in the
mod and I'm not really good did that
beer knew you'd have one fire I have a
question about the google drive the
Google Drive SDK you think that this is
the right place to ask for disgusting we
can try an answer we don't know where
for ya oh yeah yeah plumber you need
Richard Nick here they can go around
doing a developer days on their sake but
yeah go for it no car let's go well I'm
trying to get the token out rotation
using the new google play services and i
combine this with the Google Drive SDK
sometimes the google group the Google
Drive SDK platoon to me and now object
now another exception on on the upload
of the file but this happened very very
random so this is not a back but it does
something concerning the web server or I
don't know the surfaces from driver
anyone got some experience about that
and I probably I'd probably guess that
is the connection here maybe maybe the
connection dropped out for a millisecond
wally was uploading and it doesn't do
any rich frien so you want me to do
implement that yourself no no no I
already tried to clean the cash and
everything i also found on Stack
Overflow a question like this without
any answers if you want I can shave the
question because I believe that there is
some some problem with the services and
yeah share the question and the
Socko flow link and we'll try and give
it to rich and Nick because I've got the
farmer experience with the drive SDK one
right now ok ok I would I will find
right now and I'm putting the tractor
you can go try to another question with
someone else kids that they um leave a
question in the chat are getting us a
moderator yeah it's got some moderator
questions on the go right so is question
from Jay Dixon they asked is there a kit
as a cast management in the Google Play
in-app purchase sort of flow in version
for it because asking how I should clear
the cache when you actually making
changes source of prices to items to
whatever you need to read and tej what's
up no no you go from okay yeah so from
what I gather when you make any changes
to your sort of in-app purchases in app
purchases and the Google Play client
actually notified and it will invite
invalidate is cash and so I'm pretty
sure you can just assume that any call
that you make the cash is valid that's a
pretty safe assumption I guess you need
time you might see issues as it does
take it up while though updates in the
play store when it comes to filling to
actually felt through to the app so you
might have to wait a little while for
that to go through but if you've got
more solid example that plus another
question but yeah I think they say
Google Play all sorted out Andrew Kelly
is asked can you please confirm the
current refund period on the google play
store and is there any way to query what
type mrs. I'd like to answer to this no
you cannot hurt and the main reason I
kind of like that is to simplify that if
you terrified that out I question what
you're trying to do with it I like the
idea well I don't like the idea but I
just can easily see how people would
take advantage of that until you change
one
so I I can gather it's not going to
change for a while so that way if he
does and what we don't know yeah that's
for answering our guitar if if the
Google Play team decide they want to
change it then it is probably due to
custom demand and they've obviously got
a good reason doing it and obviously
that's when we'll make public statement
etc it's not a regular occurrence it's
not going to be something that happens
dynamically yeah I think we've got
support we're changing it regularly it
would confuse developers as well as
consumers which we don't want to do
we've got some more questions the matter
actually yeah how difficult is it to
enable printing from within Android how
different are the API is for version two
a version for Kevin I have no experience
of the google print API so I couldn't
comment you play with it I have a
pleasure I don't know um to be very
honest there might be a question to try
again next week we can probably copy it
over from muttering haps rich or make or
have a better idea if not we'll go away
and look at it and come back then answer
yeah I'll have a look at this exclusive
coming recently sir I'm a chance looking
any more question so there's question
can anyone tell me how to override /
hide outgoing calling screen in android
chandra i think i should have just
destroyed that name sorry if I have so
yeah chris is kind of point now there's
the action new outgoing call broadcast
which you can essentially register to be
overridden I also recommend looking at
sipdroid it's an open source voice over
IP app but Germany I'd say look at the
documentation a good idea what's going
on and then if you want to look at any
examples then situate quite nice way of
then going and digging around I'd worry
about why you try and do this if you're
trying to implement calling yourself
like if you try and create a VoIP client
or for something and then yes the valid
use case but if you're trying to sort
hide someone's trying to call Vidya Sam
or whatever I'd worry about that because
I'm not sure what you need to do that
yeah I think it's a bit of a niche use
case i think the time i had to look at
it was a company that wanted to tell
whether you were making an international
call or not but yeah I'd say be very
careful because they say you're kind of
dish just kind of integrating really
heavily with the core purpose of
someone's phone especial know what the
layout is how to sort of turn the
speaker on laughs mute or I kind of
stuff I think it's a prime candidate for
just give me a tutorial that's like
what's going to happen when they can
stalled your app and unable to learn
things so fun oh yeah oh if anyone has
questioned life feel free two years
strong it in so Andrew Kelly another
question I funding and with the drawable
no DPI bucket could you give an
explanation of what you want to use this
and how would the image look on an xhdpi
device compared to an NDP onto us what
we don't want this to happen we just had
a brief discussion about it before it
came out like so and yeah so basically
if you think of mdp oltp etc as being a
bucket it's a range of that's pixel
density displays and it's kind of
simplifies the way the developers can
think about the UI in terms of just
roughly if it's mdpi that it will use
this asset and that's all I have to
worry about as opposed to each
individual one but it will still get
some level of scaling now I'd say you
probably don't have that much of a use
case of wanting to use no DPI Chris get
these on the way you wanted to handle
the scaling yourself which is valid I've
used it in the past where I've wanted to
literally just have a pixel perfect
image for one single device that was not
going to be distributed anywhere I'd
argue if you were using it then you're
probably using it in such a niche use
case that you'll completely aware that
what the limitations are going to be but
yeah generally I take most people
wouldn't need to it's only if you need
to get it out unscaled untouched pixel
for pixel exactly the same but yeah the
other Lance to that one a primary mm so
example of how when to use it is in
documentation 24 widget previews of
inversion free almonds you got that sort
of the end rich net widgets illicitly a
gridview mark on stuff and and the
documentation says to put your widget
preview mode epi just cuz they love the
launcher does all the scanning for you
and as an example is it's just it can
you meet Amit abuses you want to scan
yourself yeah Ryan hidden gems of the
android box here he Brooks last are
there any suggestions for responding to
other apps affecting your app but not
free not audio channels given the photo
max or yelling and really limit um not
really and there's no way you can really
control what audio manager and how that
sort of dispute is channels so there is
no wait really and yeah I think
generally is a case of kind of the honor
system if you're hanging around with
that kind of stuff honor when your talk
to kind of choice I thought to do it
yeah I can't think of any situations how
you could overcome that beyond kind of
in form of the user about what's going
on and kind of telling them we're trying
to do this we can't because of other
applications perhaps consider closing
them I'd be interesting what scenarios
you've got for this for what apps are
using so many channels and could be
interesting of how they're trying to use
so many channels to sort of user element
yeah so if you can give them their levin
response on
the cheetah band rule and think so they
live in on the page I'm having a
persistent but sporadic problem with my
web view it's consistent across
different handsets and I have no clue on
what to do snap overflow from mini bill
I like the name okay so on for dot 0 dot
1 the web view shows a blank page around
me okay i'm using so it looks like
they're just trying to display some data
just as a string rather than loading
from a web service doing a set of
encoding can't say i can give you an
answer to that one would that lifeline
yeah that's not one candidate so does
anyone else have any questions in the
Hangout come on some of us everyone oh
yeah we have a good bang every one of
the Google+ yes look there's not much
questions either there no no okay I'm
gonna bring poppers today thank you my
question about the video of you again so
y'all see can you hear me now yeah I can
eat it okay sorry about the video of you
again um basically what I did again just
stripped all the beautiful image buttons
and Robles and stuff from the video view
and put it on the View for a viewpager
it's working on the viewpager so sorry
Let Die buttons ain't working no no
buttons and it's working it's loading
the video i can click on it and play
click again in the impulses and resume
and so on and so any suggestions where
to dig up or to see why when I'm at
an image overlay or something on top of
it the videos and there's a flag on
surface here from our remember I'll have
a quick dig now and see what I find it
you can might be able to notice I've
seen people overlay their own buttons on
video yeah i just posted on a chat some
simple app i just stumbled upon it's
called the video super pop up or
something like that i don't i'm not sure
and basically what it does it has some
nice and neat you I hacking to enable a
pop-up of all the video you playing
basically as a drag window all over your
home screen is a widget resizable inside
other applications and basically you
have a window with the video playing and
you can interact with the entire screen
with different activities I think it's
using something they changes but I'm not
sure so I've seen examples of done a
very simplistic apps I think my biggest
concern is the fact that because it's in
a viewpager as well whether we're
getting to a point where something's
just not quite saying well you said he
just likes not working but it's not
working it in out of the EU pager so if
you don't use a viewpager it does muskie
but same problem and no the second the
same problem can get the chem play video
file basically when I have the video
view inside the viewpager it works
outside of your pager it works if i add
buttons on top of it it doesn't work but
this did you say it's not happening
across is it happening a colossal
versions of android no I'm just testing
on my Nexus 7 and my galaxy nexus I
didn't test on Android
2.3 or a gingerbread or so oh there's a
method on surface you called set Z order
on top which will make your service view
a clucker well try and draw like a
normal view so if you can try an access
to the surface view from video view and
then call that method send it to true
and it might work but like I also some
Peter Brooks posted on the chat we
overlay buttons on the video a lot on
our app yeah which app any cool temple
because surface you said the order on
top oh it's a game brokens word
okay since your turn yeah I'll Canberra
can get surface food videos you I think
not no I think I need to override video
view or extend over a video of you and
then try and get some I extend services
yeah you can just call set the order on
top from on the video of you you should
work but it will call I don't get work
but basically the sets the order is just
to change the stacking of the elements
on the layers um yeah it are currently
exactly in service he works but without
it sort of punches view from the back of
your window whereas you be called true
on settled the order on top it doesn't
special stuff wherever it kind of
proxies the view so it's sort it looks
like it's a normal view and but arc I
remember the exact details are I've done
this kind of thing before and doing that
worked so but I don't know about your
sorry i cannot be quite interesting if
you can like code up a small sample
that's doing is that the same thing
it'll be interesting to see hey all i'll
try to dig out only the specific sample
for the viewpager and stuff not again
and baby do some and github or something
i'm not sure i'm not sure it will work
because basically i've tried to do it in
the last couple of hours and that's the
first time I saw something like that cuz
I did video views before and never had
the problem of doing an image overlay on
top of it or yeah yeah how's that
familiar with it so we've been joined by
someone else and Australia any other
questions maybe Peter the answer one of
Peters yeah that's one of Pete books if
not it's me from google plus we had like
a Google+ was empty I think we've gone
through yep I I can I like to ask
another question if ya girlfriend you
this time yeah yeah so can I how do I
know if an action is found on the split
action bar instead of the original
action bar you don't with action
mashallah perhaps like I said I I don't
know i'm sure you could somehow that
mean it's supposed to be transparent so
you're not supposed to know but you
supposed to sell the app and then the
action bar was showing on certain
devices and mainly cell phones or sore
small devices yeah but if i use
different backgrounds for like one light
and the other one dark so so what was
that so you can use a light background
on the split yeah and dark and dark
background on the original and then i
need to switch icons to the shoulder
contrast uh I understand um don't
forgive you Alice to know and you just
want to get some different IDs I guess
I know I don't think I control that is
and I know what the ideas are uh yeah
definite any way you can do it okay
there's nowhere I found out where we can
be alone that's right know what Charlie
and I didn't hear that while I try they
the recording thank you I don't oh no no
no back up I she often was probably not
realistic cool well I guess we don't
have any other questions and looks
overdone anyone else last chance name
once going twice sold to the game
videographer oh ok guys thank you very
much yes thanks next week yeah bye
cheers guys